Alhamdulillah.
Continuing
in the chapter of the chapter of
patience
from the illustrious book
authored by
Andi
mentions very strategically after the
first verse to introduce the topic. IC
he began with a command.
Anything that Allah commands
is an act of worship.
And any act of worship worship garers
love from Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
How does a person earn Allah's love? By
worshiping him in the way that he has
commanded. Subhanahu wa ta'ala. Anything
that he commands, we know that this is
an act of worship because he only
commands with that which he loves.
Subhanahu wa ta'ala.
The command that in Noah we began with.
Oh you who have believed
exude patience, exhibit patience,
practice patience, be patient.
The next verse he mentions is almost a
response to the other side of that and
that is what can we expect
to
have to exhibit patience in the face of.
There will be
there will be difficulty. There will
be trial, tribulation.
There will be testing.
What can we expect? In what facets of
our lives will these trials and
tribulations take place?
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says in verse
number 155 of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says that
which translates to and verily indeed
by Allah we are going to test you all
with a portion of fear and hunger
and a lack of
various types of wealth
and a lack of bodies or a lack of
lives
and a lack of fruits.
and give glad tidings to those who are
patient.
This statement of Allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala
we indeed verily are going to test you
all with a portion
of fear.
The person's life is not going to be
entirely
enveloped in fear nor entirely enveloped
in a complete and utter lack of
resources
every single waking moment. There may be
long portions of that, long terms of
that. But every person in this world, no
matter how good he is and no matter how
bad he is, will have an element of
happiness in his or her life and an
element of sadness in his or her life,
an element of
difficulty and an element of ease.
He says subhanahu wa ta'ala a portion of
fear.
Fear of one's mortality, fear of death,
fear of
all of the things that usually scare
the human being. fear over one's
self, over one's wealth, over one's
family, over one's state,
property, etc. Fear.
He mentions hunger.
This is something that
some of us
have
not really felt forced upon us in a very
long time.
But Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has
commanded that we fast in order to
always
keep in mind what it is to need, what
it is to want. When the person is
constantly satisfied all of the time and
satisfaction becomes the norm,
this is where entitlement comes from.
This is where a person becomes soft
and unable to recognize
a
blessing for what it is. And so we have
been commanded by Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala to fast. We have been commanded
by Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala to give.
We've been commanded by Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala to set aside time to pray and
so forth in order that our thankfulness
be in line with our blessings. He says,
"And a lack or a depletion of different
types of wealth, a depletion of souls
and bodies, a depletion of fruits. And
this last one, a lack of fruits.
This is a major major
test from Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
It's speaking about physical fruits.
Yes, of course. Where a person may work
his entire year in order to plant his
crop and the yield of fruits at the end
of that egregious time is very
underwhelming or maybe done away with
entirely physically. but also
metaphorical fruits as the companions
have pointed out.
Fruits of one's labor, the payoff of
patience.
A person is going to be tested by that.
And this is a test that many of us
fail. Many human beings fail. But not
only is it a test of will we fail or
succeed in that test, but will it change
our course?
What does that mean? One of the fruits
of patience is victory. As the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam said, one of
the fruits of good deeds
is that good will spread. One of the
fruits of teaching is that people
will learn. One of the fruits of
fighting is that peace will prevail. One
of the etc. There's always an end goal
in what we strive for.
But will our striving suffer if we don't
see those fruits?
If we fight and fight and fight and it
seems there's no peace in in in
sight.
If we teach and teach and teach and it
seems that no one is accepting. If the
prophets and messengers call their
people and no one accepts Islam. If a
person pardons only to never be pardoned
by others. If a person is generous only
to never be shown generosity by others.
This is a lack of immediate fruit.
Person is being rewarded but the
immediate fruit is not there
and that reinforces a person's actions.
Will this
change a person's
course?
Meaning will I continue to be good
no matter if the fruits present
themselves or not. Am I doing this for
the sake of Allah or am I doing this
because I am looking for the fruits of
my labor in this life. This is a major
major test
was tested with this for 950
years.
950 years he was tested with calling his
people and no one would answer his call.
Very very few people accepted Islam
after a legacy spanning centuries.
Almost an entire millennium of calling
people to Islam and very few people
responded.
If we were to look at
at the beginning and at the end,
was he equally as intense?
Was he equally as committed? or when he
saw a lack of fruits, did he become
slower to the calling of his people?
Did this deter him from calling to Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala? This is the lack of
fruits that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
tests us with.
Subhanah.
Subhanahu waala
which is